[Music]
yo what's up mkbhd here welcome back to
dope tech i love doing these the series
where i find the dopest tech
and then share it with you so we got a
couple things with this one first one is
these these are
battery banks this is the shar geek
storm 2 and storm 2 slim uh let's be
honest most battery banks are basically
the same thing right they're all kind of
boring but i have gone on to basically
replace all of my functional battery
banks in my life with these
because they're the same thing but
cooler you know maybe transparent tech
is having a moment here in 2022 because
we've seen the nothing phone the nothing
earbuds and some other transparent stuff
logically why not try it with power
banks too and it turns out it looks sick
so basically all power banks inside they
have got to have batteries they also
have a logic board and some ports this
one does a great job of being able to
see straight inside i would say in a
tasteful way but i also haven't flown
with this yet and so i kind of wonder
what the tsa would think about this
design luckily it's got a little label
that says airline safe on it that should
do it but i think the best part is it's
actually a really good power bank so all
the ports are on one side here the small
one the slim has one usb a and one usbc
and it's 20 000 milliamp hours that's
enough to fully charge a brand new
macbook air and i say that because it
also outputs enough power to do exactly
that the usbc port here will output up
to a hundred watts and the best part is
there's this little screen here on the
power bank that lights up when it's
doing something it has all kinds of
nerdy information about every single
little thing that's going on in real
time so your charging power wattage
amperage temperature and everything it's
actually sick so yeah as soon as i plug
something in i know how much power it's
giving or receiving i don't know if you
remember that cable i showed that's in
the what's in my bag video that also
showed how much power was going through
it on a tiny screen but this is kind of
like that but with any cable you want so
the bigger version has more ports and
it's also bigger so it has more capacity
this one is 25 600 milliamp hours that
will charge a 14-inch macbook pro from
zero to a hundred in an hour and a half
so i guess what i'm trying to say is
unless the airline's taken from me i'm
gonna use these for everything now i
really like them i use them currently we
use it literally to power the mixed pre
3 that my my audio device is for
recording videos they have this terrible
design where you need a power bank
instead of putting batteries on the back
because it blocks the sd card slot
anyway
i'm loving them they're both 200. not
cheap but
hey
this is dope tech
okay so this thing
is ridiculous so samsung reached out and
they wanted to sponsor a look at their
new odyssey arc gaming monitor
i've seen some pretty crazy monitors in
my time
but nothing like this so this is a
massive 55 inch corner to corner 165
hertz curved gaming monitor pretty sure
it's the only monitor in the world with
that exact spec and it has a one
millisecond response time plus it's amd
freesync premium pro certified so it's
definitely built for gaming and in every
way this thing is ridiculous it
basically feels like putting a tv on
your desk but way more powerful and it
needs some pretty serious hardware like
this huge
foot wide metal stand and the mount
that's attached to it to hold the whole
thing above your desk so why would
someone get something like this like
what is this capable of well turns out
pretty much everything so it plugs in
via this box back here like some other
samsung tvs and there's four total hdmi
2.1 ports on the box so you can give it
a bunch of inputs and then there's this
remote like it looks kind of like a
skinny tv remote that comes with it and
there's also this which is called the
arc dial it's kind of crazy i've never
seen anything like this before but
basically instead of having to reach all
the way around the back of this huge
monitor you have the controls
on this dial and it connects wirelessly
via bluetooth and that's how you get to
your settings and control this monitor
so you can set it anywhere you want at
your desk for your controls and both
this and the remote have solar panels on
them so you should actually pretty much
never need to charge them which is super
smart so this arc dial will let you
control pretty much everything about
this monitor but when you're just using
it like a normal monitor not even gaming
just for productivity and stuff like
that it's still
very impressive it is a huge monitor and
at this resolution it can fit a ton of
stuff on the screen any app or program
that benefits from spreading things out
will never look better than it does on
this monitor also the whole thing has a
matte anti-glare finish that cuts down
on reflections or any lights that may be
in your living space and you can put
tons of things on the screen to your
heart's content and i feel like because
of the curve you know it's not as neck
breaking as something this size would be
if it was flat so just so you know this
is called a 1000r curve monitor because
the radius of the circle that this
monitor would make if you extended it
all the way around into a circle is 1000
millimeters so the smaller the number
the more pronounced the curve and this
one curves so much that the upper and
lower corners really do stretch into
your peripheral vision just gives you
maximum immersion and then as you can
imagine
it's incredible for gaming so i've gamed
on a lot of nice monitors in the past
couple years and also tried gaming on
tvs in the past this isn't quite like
either one of those experiences because
the size and the height and the sheer
curve and the image quality it's just an
amazing setup for pretty much any game
that you throw at it also the speakers
built in aren't bad either there's four
speakers at each corner and two central
woofers so just with the monitor's
built-in speakers you're getting a dolby
atmos setup and it can help with object
tracking sound because the left and
right channels are so far apart this is
a quantum mini led display at 4k
resolution so there's legitimately
details in the darkest and brightest
parts of scenes and games but also
samsung says there is a multi-layer
neural network for upscaling but just
like playing a game full screen
obviously it's incredible but let's say
your neck does get tired right you're
not really so used to turning your head
as much or maybe you're just super used
to playing a game on a smaller screen
like a 24 inch or 27 inch screen right
all right no problem so this arc dial
lets you pop into a setting called flex
move screen you hit that and then you
can literally drag down the size of the
monitor to whatever size you want it to
be you want a 30 inch monitor you want a
27 you want a 24 22 whatever all these
different sizes are available to you it
kind of looks
crazy tiny you can move it around maybe
put it in the middle so you're not
looking down all the time
there's your smaller monitor it's
convenient fun fact this graphic that's
behind whatever your screen would be
actually changes based on what's on your
screen so it matches the colors if it's
dark then it'll be dark if it's bright
and colorful then it'll match the colors
but probably the most extreme feature of
them all this whole thing this gigantic
panel rotates 90 degrees to create this
towering 55-inch diagonal monstrosity
that's literally curved over your head
basically towering over you so seeing
this monitor in portrait mode is wild
and there are even a couple window
management features to help you make the
most of this ridiculous amount of
vertical screen real estate here you can
see it mimicking three 27-inch monitors
stacked on top of each other each with
something completely different going on
the screen so productivity can be fun
each of these windows is the size of an
entire monitor and if you're feeling
bold it's actually the world's best
shorts or reels or tick-tock monitor
where you can truly kick back and
immerse yourself and waste unbelievable
amounts of time there's actually also a
feature called eclipse sync which has
two lights on the back of the monitor
that will change colors based on what's
in the game to reflect off the wall for
even further immersion but let's be
honest most of the time your eyes are
going to be all over this display all
the time now this is dope tech so we
know it's the craziest leading edge
stuff but if you do want to actually get
your hands on something like this it'll
run 3 500 and if you want to justify it
you could say
it's kind of like having
three or four monitors in one so
yeah shout out to the odyssey arc for
that
that brings me to my third and final
item here now as you can imagine the
webcam situation with a huge monitor
with any huge monitor can be pretty
crazy but also
webcams generally are pretty trash but
then this insta360 link webcam started
showing up on my feed actually a lot in
the last couple days there's a bunch of
sponsored videos this one clearly isn't
sponsored by them but i did get my hands
on it and i wanted to check it out and
it turns out it is really cool and very
impressive for certain groups of people
so first of all if you're just looking
for a quality upgrade a dedicated webcam
will always give you that over a
built-in so with this one you're getting
a half inch sensor
4k 30fps video
phase detect autofocus this is easily
miles better than any normal built-in
webcam into any computer it's kind of
like the opel c1 but they're both like a
step below
using your literal iphone as your webcam
with continuity camera but as you can
tell just by looking at it it's this
little rig here it's about more than
just the camera quality it is all about
the features so you can see it's got an
entire gimbal built in like someone
sawed it off the bottom of a drone and
stuck it onto a webcam
and the world of motion controlled video
camera just opened up a world of
possibilities so having a swiveling
tilting articulating camera as a webcam
means it can follow you around and track
you around a room no matter where you go
and it is
a thousand percent faster and more
responsive than like what we've seen
when apple does the super ultra wide
camera and then does center stage and
crops in
this just
this is i feel like i can walk around
the room and it'll follow me so this
will clearly be pretty sick for
streamers uh but i think underrated it
would actually be
even better probably for remote work and
remote learning things like that um
because continuing along the theme of
this being the smartest webcam i've ever
used it can obviously use the gimbal to
point in any direction so it's a really
solid desk view because as you can
imagine it literally just tilts down and
points more directly at your desk and
then proceeds to use
sort of extra processing to create a
pseudo top-down view kind of like what
apple did with continuity camera but
then probably the most useful one
there's these tracker stickers that come
with the webcam all you have to do is
put one on each corner of a whiteboard
and then move the whiteboard somewhere
into frame and then all you have to do
is give it a peace sign and it'll go
into whiteboard mode you can see the
whiteboard over there behind me it's not
even like in the normal frame of view of
the webcam i'm just going to give it a
peace sign it blinks it goes into
whiteboard mode and it sort of
locates the whiteboard takes a second
you can see it going over my shoulder
there
that's the whiteboard and then it snaps
in
and now
you're fully on the whiteboard well you
miss some
i'm teaching
i'm instructing things on the whiteboard
from across the room
so easy like this is everything apple
center stage ever it to be obviously
they want you to be able to put your
ipad down and walk around the kitchen
and it follows you but yeah this will
literally follow you and complete 360
degree around your laptop it's it's much
better so yeah i'll give it another
peace sign it'll realize it can go back
to me snaps back to me
and then uh yeah we're just using the
webcam like normal again but it also has
a feature which is when you stop using
it so i'll stop recording and then you
close the app and it goes to sleep after
a while it just shuts down and faces
straight down which is sort of a privacy
feature which just means it won't be
able to look up and at you
it's nice that a webcam that can turn
around doesn't when you're not using it
it's a privacy feature so yeah i think
that's gonna that's gonna easily qualify
for the smartest webcam i've ever tried
uh but it's pretty smart that a camera
company is what insta360 is is making a
webcam so that's that's why it's also
fantastic quality and everything else
that's around it works pretty well so
yeah pretty sick that's why it's dope
tech so that's it for this one a super
cool clear battery bank an insane 55
inch super curved gaming monitor and the
smartest webcam that i've ever tried
i
really enjoy doing dope tech videos and
i'm glad we're bringing them back i'm
kind of surprised we haven't done more
we'll probably do another one soon
in any case thanks for watching this one
subscribe to see the next one when it
comes out and i'll talk to you guys in
the next one
peace
[Music]